Ngoài nè 1 2 3 năm năm 2020, bán phòng cơ quan cạnh rất đều trà công an tình vô đánh ám,
cho biết đã hình chương phối hợp các đình viện nghi vụ linh quan đều trà,
làm só vụ trẻ ô tô sử dát tại kây sang Pé Chô Liên Mí số Chín Nguyễn Tung Tú Mỹ,
sát hình định khiến hai người từ vòng.
Tung Tín Bà đầu khoảng 152 mila phút hùng qua,
xe ô tô chỉ mấy hai ai ai sau năm XX cho vóuễn duyên,
xin năm 2020, chú xa thân định điều khiến lẽ và chủ bân sẵn số 1 của kêu cây sang để đủ sang.
Chè xe lúc này còn có tên hát tê, xin năm 2020,
và đe à ca, xin năm 2020 cũng chú xa thân định.
Hí nhân viên kây sang của đưa vào bông ra để chân vị tiếp như lựa tý bất ngờ
phân côp sau xe phết nổ, họ lửa bùng phát sửa bảo trường phương tịt,
phát hiện sự việc, nhân viên kây sang cùng người dân và lựa ngỗ trợ
tại chỗ nhìn trong sự dụng mình chứ trái để giập lửa.
Hòa 155, đám trái được không xế, tinh nhân khi tiếp cận phương tịt
lực lựa chức năng phát hiện thay nạn như là tê và ca đã tử vòng bên trong xe.
Qua xác mình bà đầu, các quan chức năng xác định tại thư điểm xe ra vụ trái,
xe xe có CHU khoảng 205 khối adulthood,
c控 chiến định át phủy xe định đồ trôi trái em đã được sản rate.
Hịnh các quan phong năng tiếp tục với hợp ở đơn vịnh nghi vụ khám nghĩa phương tịt
giả miệng nguyên chuyến nổ, đông thư cùng của sơ, đưa tra làm sáo vụ việc
để rửa lý theo đúng quy định của phát lado.
Lên quan đến tụ việc, thời gian qua, trên một số trang mạng số hợp sất hiện nhiều thông tin sư diễn
đăng tay nổi xung cho được kìm chiến định nguyên nghiên vụ chuyến nổ.
người hoang mang dưới lận và làm xa lịch bản chất thủ vật.
Cô phán công an phuyên cáo hử dân cần tình gáo,
tiếp tận thông tin từ các muốn chính thống.
Không chia sẻ, phát tản các thông tin chưa được các quan chính năng kiến chứng.
Cô chính hợp đăng tải thông tin sai sự thật người an ngộn đến tình gình an in chật tử sẽ bị sư liên nghiênh thọc vi địa của phát lật.